[Musica]
allora io sono qui per parlarvi del
programma erasmus dell'unione europea
perché l'ho inventato io
tanti anni fa le cose sono andate così
io ero studentessa di giurisprudenza ho
vinto una borsa di studio fulbright
prestigiosissima e sono andata alla
columbia university per un intero anno
accademico a studiare giurisprudenza
diritto comparato mi hanno alla fine del
di tutto l'anno accademico me hanno dato
il titolo di master in diritto comparato
cerimonia bellissima sul prato della
columbia university io col cappelletto
quadrato come si vede nei film
torno in italia e faccio la cosa che mi
sembrava più abbia vado alla segreteria
studenti della mia università per dire
guardi io quando sono partita per la
columbia university
mancavo di avere fatto cioè non avevo
ancora fatto tre gli ultimi tre esami
per poi fare la tesi e prendere la
laurea in giurisprudenza ho studiato un
anno alla columbia university per
piacere calcola temi gli studi fatti
alla colombia come equivalenti a quei
tre esami che ancora mi mancavano così
io faccio la tesi di laurea e mi laureo
in fretta
e qui è cominciato tutto
l'impiegato allo sportello non ha
nemmeno capito cosa io gli stavo
chiedendo ha chiamato il direttore della
segreteria e quale è venuto allo
sportello e anziché starmi ad ascoltare
mi ha fatto una tremenda ramanzina che
non esagero ma signorina lei cosa crede
lei se ne va a spasso a divertirsi per
il mondo
e poi noi abbiamo fatto così noi
dovremmo darle una laurea ma per carità
ma vada a casa si metta a studiare veda
di farsi promuovere per me non era mai
stato un problema farmi promuovere
perché ha messo odiare era sempre
piaciuto perciò non c'era proprio un
problema per me a farmi promuovere non
c'è stato niente da fare
ma poi siccome io insistevo e lui
imperversava sempre di più a un certo
punto si era fatta una coda di studenti
dietro di me e questo andava avanti
imperterrito il pubblico a insultarmi
non gli ho dato addirittura in mano la
pergamena cia che mi avevano consegnato
in occasione della cerimonia la colombia
quello la prenda ci dà un'occhiata
sdegnata e legge columbia university mai
sentita nominare mi sono dovuta
rassegnare poi umiliata per essere stata
sgridata pubblicamente quasi accusa
senza e quasi accusata di avere voluto
avere delle qui polenz e per degli studi
fatti o all'università delle isole
cayman o in qualche omologo dei paradisi
fiscali doveva li paghi e poi ti porti a
casa un titolo di studio
cosa che la columbia university
assolutamente non è è una delle
università più prestigiose del mondo
se uno vuole elencare le dieci
università più prestigiose del mondo fra
le 10 la colombia university
c'è sicuramente insomma non c'è stato
niente da fare
a me studiare piaceva ha studiato i tre
esami sono andata a sostenere gli esami
e mi sono laureata è qui è cominciata la
bella sorpresa perché mentre i miei
colleghi di studio che non erano andati
a fare questa esperienza di un anno di
studio all'estero il lavoro lo dovevano
cercare non era poi esattamente così
facile non era come oggi però l'italia è
sempre stata un paese in cui c'è più
disoccupazione che occupazione
insomma io avevo invece non ero io che
andavo a cercare i datori di lavoro
erano il datore di lavoro che cercavano
me allora io ho detto ma se questa cosa
ha fatto tanto bene a me cerchiamo di
generalizzarla avessi mai detto sono
stata di nuovo ripetutamente insultato o
lasci perdere ma signora niente non uno
che mi chiamasse dottoressa signora
lasci perdere questa è un'idea balzana
non otterrà mai niente ma scusi
quell'ironia i nostri professori non
sono abbastanza buoni per per questi
studenti che lei vorrebbe mandarli a
studiare all'estero ma è lo stesso
motivo per cui la dirette fa un viaggio
anziché rimanere ferma in casa propria
non c'è stato niente da fare
ma io non mi sono mai resa conto che la
cosa sarebbe stata così difficile
insomma io ho dovuto battagliare 18 anni
ma avessero detto guardi lei dovrà
battagliare 18 anni io mi sarei
rassegnata avrei fatto qualcos'altro ma
io credevo sempre che l'ultimo ostacolo
che io ero riuscita a superare sarebbe
stato l'ultimo
e invece no superato un ostacolo
l'immobilismo della burocrazia italiana
inventava sempre un altro ostacolo poi
dai e dai i tempi sono maturati
io sono riuscita a mano a mano ha perso
avere più persone
insomma alla fine ci siamo arrivati e
nel 1987 dopo 18 anni di lotta
una sperimentazione amplissima che è
durata dieci anni che ha scambiato ha
scambiato ha realizzato dei progetti di
scambio in numero superiore a 500 questa
non è una sperimentazione
questo è un mega progetto pilota
insomma dal 1987 è in funzione questo
programma erasmus dell'unione europea e
che cosa fa è un complesso di
finanziamenti di provvidenze mari perché
e qui cito la costituzione è la
costituzione o parla o non parla e se
parla parla chiaro e chi la può citare
non deve proprio tener temere ulteriori
obiezioni la costituzione della
repubblica italiana oltre a tutti i
documenti interni
azionari recita testualmente i capaci e
meritevoli anche se privi di mezzi hanno
diritto di raggiungere i gradi più alti
degli studi
perciò capaci vuol dire che abbiano le
doti naturali di intelligenza per poter
affrontare degli studi di livello molto
avanzato meritevole cioè che si
applicano allo studio vanno all'estero
con borse di studio e quando ritornano
quegli studi che hanno fatto all'estero
vengono loro calcolati come se gli
avessero fatti in patria non è mica una
scoperta che andare per un anno a fare
un viaggio culturale all'estero fa bene
ai giovani quando solo lì sui 20 22 anni
ha certamente tant'è vero che le
famiglie ricche i loro giovani appare un
anno di studio all'estero il grand tour
si faceva nel settecento nel 1700 e
faceva tanto bene solo che potevano
partecipare solo quei giovani che per
combinazione erano stati dalla cicogna
recapitati in una famiglia abbiente
mentre invece quelli che erano stati
recapitati da un'altra cicogna in una
famiglia che ambiente non opposte no
allora studi esteri niente sentite
io ero sostenuta da due cose terribili e
da un incoraggiamento costante e 2 cosa
terribile è che eravamo in periodo di
guerra fredda e c'era un europa
ancora molto disastrata non erano poi
passati tanti anni dalla fine della
seconda guerra mondiale che aveva
attraversato l'europa facendo di
istruzioni terribili
poi c'era una reazione strana se parlavo
con dei piccoli burocrati allora a no
signora lasci perdere ma che è sta
storia alla pazzia da altre parlavo con
dei grandi scienziati perché io avevo
occasione di avvicinarlo di grandi
scienziati allora i grandi scienziati
non mi lasciavano parlare per più di
dieci o venti secondi si signora ma che
bella idea 11 che aveva tutti i titoli
per essere considerato uno scienziato
veramente grande
ascoltava ero arrivata su ciò il 20
secondo del mio discorso
e questo mi ascoltava facendo cenni di
assenso
e intanto si frugava nel taschino dico
cosa cerca alla fine trova quel che
cerca la era la penna signora signora
dove devo firmare e 20 secondi un grande
scienziato si era totalmente persuaso ma
chi era un grande studioso si è perso
aveva immediatamente erano i piccoli
burocrati che non riuscivo a 9 insomma
farle la breve dal 1987
la cosa ha cominciato a funzionare
arrivano i danari l'unione europea ha
organizzato un agenzia centrale a
bruxelles con decine di alti funzionari
in gambissime poliglotti qual è il
plurale di paul io ma pare insomma che
tutti parlano benissimo
due o tre lingue anche tre o quattro
erogano ogni anno puntualmente delle
somme enormi per dare le borse di studio
perché chi sia lì famiglia abbiente
chiede i soldi alla famiglia ma tv
famiglia ambiente non sia ha bisogno che
ci sia l'unione europea
i governi le regioni che lo finanziano e
lo fanno
e a ogni settennio perché il bilancio
dell'unione europea e settennale a ogni
settennio lo stanziamento aumenta ma non
sono danari di cui si parla che poi non
arrivano che arrivano con ritardo
no sono soldi veri arrivano sentite
ragazzi siamo tutti ragazzi
l'unico errore che non bisogna fare è
non andare astenersi dall'andare a
l'ufficio erasmus della propria
università lì tutto organizzato per voi
i soldi ci sono i soldi me li danno
l'organizzazione anche si promuove la
pace perché quando andate all'estero
cattano dei meccanismi meravigliosi d
amore fra le persone che appartengono a
culture diverse
sentite tornano tutti che le famiglie
dicono sembra una persona diversa non
sembra più quel mio figlio magari
scapestrato ma che le famiglie io ho
intervistato tutti i datori di lavoro
che assumono volentierissimo gli aironi
le famiglie che sono entusiaste
ricevo tante lettere e sapete qual è la
frase che c'è scritta di più nelle
lettere che io ricevo dagli erasmiani di
ritorno professoressa a me le ragioni mi
ha cambiato la vita
uno mi ha detto io in erasmus
ho imparato a sorridere in tutte le
lingue del mondo
arrivederci
[Musica]